people don't understand stuff you know
I'm able to sleep on this plane I pass
out I'm leaning on the side of the plane
and I am visibly passed out my eyes are
closed my mouth is hung open all right
and I keep I know myself because I keep
doing this
I'm sleeping
and now I'm in the window seat which
means there's somebody next to me I do
not know this person all right it's a
woman I do not know nice to sit next to
sweet sweet person didn't bother me we
didn't even talk right
I get this I'm on the side I'm going
what do you think about this okay I'm
leave it in the comments I'm like this I
get this
I look up
there's a guy in the um
aisle
so now I know we're going down right
because that's the only reason to wake
me up if it's just some guy
okay it wasn't a stewardess it was some
guy and he's psychic and he has a
premonition about we're going down and
the premonitions have worked out before
this
and he's got a good track record and he
knows that I have to stay safe so he
wakes me up to get into the crash
position so I'm so happy he woke me up
so I say to him yeah
I'm asleep I'm like out too I say yeah
and he says hey are you the comedian
oh we're not going down
so I say yeah and he says Chris and I
say yeah and he says can I get a picture
first of all
how
that's my first question hey guy
how hey hey guy don't turn me into an
Indian chief but
how
okay
racist
so I I say I but okay think about this
there's a woman next to me
what's the pick going to be is she gonna
be in it is he gonna do like this she's
gonna be in it do I get out
if I'm awake this is [__] bonkers
so I say he says can I get a t can I get
a picture and I say I'm sleeping man
and then he says please
and I say again I'm sleeping man
and he says okay sorry
then travel now this is the worst part
travels the rest of the way to the
bathroom didn't get up to do it
decided to bother me on the way to do
something else yo that is the most and
here's the thing about being you know in
the know or whatever you want to call it
a celebrity it sucks because he
could easily be like wow crystal is a
dick wouldn't take a picture with me
nobody would know the story
he woke me the [__] up dude
how crazy is that yo oh guess if I fell
asleep after that because of how I
because guess if I fell asleep again
after that because of how mad I was
guess if I was able to to just kind of
quell it and let it simmer guess if I
was able to do that or not oh I wasn't
dude
I really want to have a conversation
with that guy that's nuts
could you [__] believe that
I'm sleeping it wasn't like I was
hunched over I was like this
there's some [__] in the comments is
going to be like well you know you could
have gotten you know no
I can't believe that dude woke me up on
a flight for a pick for real I mean just
lost my freaking mind
I was talking to Lulu about it and she
was like man if I saw that I would have
said something